j'ai j'ai été mère pendant 20 ans de la
commune d'oulin dans le Rône j'ai vécu
des moments de tension mais finalement
pas tant que ça et pas ce niveau
d'intensité il est incontestable que
depuis quelques années la violence à
l'égard des élus en fait la violence à
l'égard de toutes les personnes ayant
autorité à fortement augmenté et non
seulement elle a augmenté mais en plus
son intensité a augmenté les gens
n'hésitent plus aujourd'hui à vouloir
tuer à vouloir blesser insulter c'est
presque un lieu commun mais l'agression
physique est de plus en plus un fait
constaté et donc dans bien raison de
nous renforcer not renforcer notre
arsenal juridique nous ne pouvons pas
laisser
faire les violences contre les élus et
contre les maires en particulier n'ont
cessé d'augmenter ces dernières années
la mort du maire de signe la démission
plus récente de maire de Saint-Brévin
Lespin l'agression contre le maire de la
île et Rose a fait qu'on ne pouvait pas
en rester en l'état nous avons décidé de
déposer une proposition de loi ce texte
renforce d'abord les quantum de peine
possi d'être prononcé contre les auteurs
de ces agressions on se met au même
niveau que les agressions contre les
personnes ayant de l'autorité publique
on a renforcé aussi rendu automatique
plutôt la protection fonctionnelle des
élus qui sont victimes d'agression de
façon à ce que les choses soient
immédiates le fait que les communes
puissent être remboursées par l'État
pour ne pas que ses frais le soit
totalement à leur charge nous avons
aussi mis en place un dispositif de
relation beaucoup plus régulière avec
les procureurs de la République de façon
à ce que l'échange d'information se
passe bien et et notamment que les
maires soient parfaitement informés de
l'état des procédures puis enfin nous
avons renforcé les moyens pour les
maires de se défendre de toutes les
attaques sur les réseaux sociaux ça
paraît essentiel aussi dans le contexte
nouveau par lequel ces violences
s'exercent voilà l'objet de ce texte il
a été voté à l'unanimité au Sénat il y a
quelques semaines et demain il sera à
l'Assemblée nationale en tous les cas
dans un un avenir très proche on espère
qu'il sera voté définitivement à partir
du début de l'année pour qu'il puisse
s'appliquer dès ce
moment-là